nos dicen una profesora compro 12 hojas
de pegatinas para usar en las tareas de
sus estudiantes cada hoja tiene 48
pegatinas al final del año a la
profesora le quedan 123 pegatinas cuál
es la mejor estimación del número de
pegatinas que usó la profesora como
siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo ustedes antes de que lo
hagamos juntos muy bien vamos a
resolverlo lo primero que tenemos que
ver es que nos piden una estimación no
al resultado exacto del número de
pegatinas usadas veamos si podemos
hacerlo nos dicen que hay 12 hojas de
pegatinas y cada hoja tiene 48 pegatinas
así que con cuentas pegatinas comenzó la
profesora son 12 hojas multiplicadas por
el número de pegatinas en cada hoja que
son 48 este es el número inicial de
pegatinas y si queremos saber el número
de pegatinas usadas tenemos que calcular
cuántas pegatinas quedaron del número
inicial y esas serán las que fueron
usadas cuántas quedaron al final del año
quedaron 123 que es este número de aquí
si calculamos esto primero el número
y le restamos la cantidad que quedó el
resultado será igual al número de
pegatinas que usó la profesora y
nuevamente no tenemos que calcular la
cantidad exacta sino sólo un estimado
por lo que vamos a encontrar números más
amigables con los que trabajar en lugar
de 12 voy a usar me quedo con el 12 es
sencillo de trabajar con el digamos que
esto va a ser aproximadamente igual a
entre paréntesis en lugar de tener 48
ponemos 50 por lo que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 12 por 50 y en
lugar de 123 vamos a usar un número más
sencillo que podría ser 120 o 100 pero
digamos que es 120 aunque pudimos usar
100 podemos hacer este cálculo
mentalmente o en un pedazo de papel 12
por 5 es 60 por lo que 12 por 50 en 600
y a 600 si tuviéramos 100 aquí 600 menos
100 sería igual a 500 pero 600 menos 120
es 480 lo que queremos hacer es ver las
opciones y elegir la que se acerque más
aquí
a 480 veamos de entre todas estas
opciones encontramos exactamente 480
elegimos esta opción y parece que en el
ejercicio estimaron lo mismo que
estimamos nosotros no todas las personas
harán lo mismo en lugar de 120 como
aproximado de 123 pudimos haber elegido
100 y entonces nos hubiera quedado 500
pero aunque nuestro estimado fuera 500
480 seguiría siendo la opción más
cercana a nuestra estimación